als sich dieses foto hier gesehen habe
ein mann mit einem halben kopf ist das
photoshop oder was ist das nein ist
leider ist ja das ist so michael brocke
der ist 28 jahre alte brite lag wie sie
sehen lange im krankenhaus und hinter
diesem foto steckt diese geschichte er
hat sich bei einer firmenfeier
schrecklich bedruckt man muss sagen er
hat sich da wirklich mehr eingestellt
als nötig war und dann weglaufen gemacht
folge war gehirnschaden und ganz ganz
viele operationen ja und jetzt will er
schadenersatz und das ist schon
spektakulär nämlich von seinen chefs
also die die feier da veranstaltet haben
er will schadenersatz von der
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft pwc die
hätten besser auf ihn aufpassen müssen
bei dieser feier sagt er michael bruck
ii er sei da rein getrieben worden in
dieses wettsaufen der mann heute hier an
diesem dienstag der mann mit dem halben
kopf